der paragrafenreiter ein
paragrafenreiter ist jemand der alle
regeln auswendig kennt und sie so oft
zitiert dass er quasi darauf herumreitet
der berufs nörgler ein berufs nörgler
ist jemand der so oft und so viel
nörgeln als wäre es sein beruf der
erbsenzähler ein erbsenzähler ist jemand
der alles ganz genau nimmt so genau dass
er sogar einen haufen erbsen zählen
würde der partymuffel ein partymuffel
ist jemand der keine partys mal der
spielverderber ein spielverderber ist
jemand der anderen das spiel und den
spaß verdirbt der haar spalter ein haar
spalter ist jemand der jedes detail so
genau nimmt dass er sogar haare spalten
würde der klugscheißer ein klugscheißer
ist jemand der glaubt dass er alles weiß
und das auch sehr gerne betont der
korinthenkacker ein korinthenkacker ist
jemand der sehr kleinlich ist und dabei
anderen menschen gegenüber oft sehr
rechthaberisch auftritt der besserwisser
ein besserwisser ist jemand der immer
alles besser weiß als die anderen
menschen
der gute laune polizist ein gute laune
polizist ist jemand der anderen gerne
den spaß verdirbt so als wäre er von der
polizei und gute laune ein verbrechen
die spaßbremse eine spaßbremse ist
jemand der anderen den spaß ausbremst